coming up for morning rounds one of the
biggest health issues lately is vaping
this can mean using e-cigarettes or
other vaping devices that contain
nicotine or THC the active ingredient in
marijuana according to the most recent
data from the Centers for Disease
Control
there have been 380 confirmed and
probable cases of lung related illnesses
linked to e-cigarettes or vaping
products this has occurred in 36 states
with six confirmed deaths major
questions remain here to discuss that
and more is CBS News medical contributor
dr. David agus gotta ask you this never
seemed like the best idea to inhale any
substance for a lot of people so what
what is going on now you know vaping
came from a pharmacist in China said hey
there's not enough tobacco and it cost
too much for China let me figure out a
way to get nicotine into the lung and
you need a carrier molecule this
molecule carries nicotine in the lung
and it stays there and over time can
cause problems so you know it took over
two decades to show that smoking tobacco
caused lung cancer and when we put this
on the market and we allow kids to use
it really without long-term testing bad
things can happen I think that's what
we're seeing now and so it scares me
that we're doing experiments with
children and there's new regulations
this week by the FDA take away all the
flavor components well hopefully limit
its use in children do you really think
though just by doing that that this is
going to hamper youths not just in
children but in adults also it's a start
you're right is I think we need a much
stronger FDA to say hey we have to test
this it's going to the lung directly to
the bloodstream we have to test this
before we allow it on the market and
when you had companies like Joo who
claimed on the package safer than
smoking and last week the FDA said hey
you can't do that until you show it
that's what we really need is we need
data so if the FDA is designing
guidelines moving forward then what
should they be doing at this moment you
know the hard part is is that you need
time right in order to test the safety
of something you have to test it for
years to see what really happens
we have to do real testing on these
compounds that kids are using we have to
do testing of things that go into the
lung to see does it cause problems with
the lung does it cause DNA changes that
can lead to cancer and the answer in
this case in many cases it's yes they do
cause problems according to the
Alzheimer's Association an estimated 5.8
million Americans are currently living
with Alzheimer's disease and by 2050 the
number is projected to rise to 14
million it's a disease that not only
impacts the patient but also their loved
ones and caregivers earlier this week
dr. Mehmet Oz announced that his mother
was diagnosed with Alzheimer's writing
in an Instagram post quote hearing the
official diagnosis was devastating but
just as painful for me was the
realization that the signs were there
all along I had just been overlooking
them and we know he's a friend of yours
in your conversations that you've had
with him since what has stood out that
line right there does when a doctor
doesn't recognize the signs first of all
when someone talks about a mistake they
made publicly to help others I think
that's powerful and Mehmet did that this
week and you know I think he felt bad
when he looked back those symptoms were
there for a year and he didn't notice
them and since then he's been tested and
he has one of the genes for Alzheimer's
and he's talked about that and we talked
about ways he can actually prevent or
delay the onset of Alzheimer's in him
and how he's taking those actions and
hopefully he could be a lesson for
others to do that are the risk factors
people can control no question is that
what you can do is things like just at
night having quiet when you have your
partner snoring or noise in the
background Street that actually your
brain needs quiet you put orange foam
earplugs you reduce the level of
cognitive decline as you get older every
year you delay retirement you reduce the
Alzheimer's by over 3% you don't use it
you lose it there are medicines that
block inflammation in the brain all of
those need to be talked about with your
doctor and your lifestyle hopefully dr.
oz stepping up can help other people
yeah they always the earlier you see
some signs the better off you are dr.
David agus double-duty for you today
thank you
good seeing